recovering from substance abuse is hard
for anyone but for children it can
impact their ability to graduate from
school Las Vegas is home to the first
publicly funded recovery High School in
the nation Joshua peguero has their
story
Landon Myers began drinking alcohol at
the age of three and by the time he was
14 started using hard drugs made cocaine
and heroin and ecstasy and drinking
codeine following a family member's
advice he enrolled at Mission High
School in 2018. the reason I'm here
today is because they changed my life
and they got me on the right path the
school opened in 2017 and was celebrated
as the first public high school in the
nation for students recovering from
substance abuse they're always going to
die out there for my drug addiction or
or the streets I OD'd so I've had
alcohol poisoning I've OD'd from drugs I
died off the drugs came back
because my heart started back up Mission
located along Veterans Memorial near
Washington currently has 24 students
enrolled principal Angelo Nichols says
it's a very intimate environment that
focuses on supporting students no one
here is judging you we want your child
well just as you want your child well
and this is a good place to get started
with that most students who attend are
referred there Nichols says they must be
open to not only recovery but for the
academic rigor out of the five current
graduating seniors three will attend
college we like to say we're a little
bit like a magnet school instead of
Automotive in our program recovery is
our program so students come here to get
the supports in the recovery process
while earning their high school credits
for graduation as for Landon Myers he
hopes others battling addiction seek
help just ask for help like it doesn't
hurt to ask and say that you're not okay
Joshua peguero eight news now
according to the Nevada Department of
Health and Human Services the number of
middle and high school students
self-reporting using marijuana and
alcohol is at its lowest level since
2017.